cars lining up around the block all to
get the most basic of human necessities
for nearly a week the people of Jackson
Mississippi have been struggling with a
serious water shortage
the National Guard are providing relief
some are happy for the help others are
growing impatient
I'm not able to cook like I want to cook
not able to brush my teeth like I want
to due to the Water Crisis
and I'm just eternally grateful that
they are the National Guard and everyone
is out you know trying to help us so we
can still have a healthy life and
maintain on a daily basis in my home the
water is running very slowly it's a
horrible situation in the entire city of
Jackson you know just not just one
individual and I blame I blame the the
city council the governor and the mayor
because they're all in confusion and no
one seemed to know how to solve the
problem
FEMA the Federal Emergency agency is
working to end the crisis
inspectors toured this water plant were
heavy rains overwhelmed the city's aging
infrastructure they're hoping to speed
up repair work but played down
expectations of a quick return to
normality yeah I think it's still too
early to tell Dana I think that having
EPA in the Army Corps of Engineers we
had a really good conversation on Friday
about what it's going to take and the
assessments that they're doing the
longer term and the midterm about how
long it's going to take to actually make
it safe to drink think that we have a
lot more to learn about what it's going
to take to get that plant up and running
in tens of thousands of homes water has
slowed to a trickle and what they do get
isn't safe to drink but this isn't a new
problem
state and federal authorities are being
blamed for allowing Jackson's
infrastructure to crumble for decades
Jackson is overwhelmingly black and many
say race is a factor
we have been getting punished for quite
some time for being a predominantly
black city
um I can recollect these issues
um for as long as I've been here and I I
was born in 1983 in Jackson
and over time the situation has gotten
worse we are not receiving any funding
from the state of Mississippi to improve
the water
Jackson's plight has grown so bad it's
received national attention
local state and federal authorities are
now focused on Distributing Aid and
getting water flowing again
but while the current crisis will
eventually be resolved correcting for
decades of neglect will be a longer term
challenge
Vincent Monaghan Al Jazeera